[Music]
his YouTube channel brew tube has a
hundred thousand subscribers and more
than 8 million views worldwide now
eddi-rue has been named as one of the
top ten educators in the in a global
teaching competition if he wins he will
bring home more than 1.2 million but how
does Australia's most famous teacher
think we can lift to stem results in
this country I spoke to him a little
earlier Eddie whoo welcome to national
rap it's so good to be here with you
pretty sure hey going good you've been
named as one of the world's top ten
educators and if you win this prize
you're gonna get over a million dollars
what are you gonna do with the money
look I have to be completely Frank with
you I've got ideas but I haven't devoted
too much thought to it because I am so
amazed by the other finalists who've
enlisted they're people who teach in
remote areas of the jungle they're
fighting gang violence reducing teen
pregnancies I don't really know if I
have that much of a shot against amazing
people like that but I just can't wait
to meet them alright let's talk about
the issues in this country universities
have been blamed for dropping eight our
entries for teachers in recent years and
also lowering the academic standards of
people going into teaching why are we
doing so badly do we need to lift those
scores what's your view I feel that the
whole conversation about scores and a
tyres and university entry when it comes
to teaching graduates kind of has a bit
of a chicken and egg problem in terms of
I think the reason why the results are
low that we have a often compared to
other countries we have a lower academic
bar set is that we simply don't have as
many people as in other countries
competing for these positions it's a bit
of a supply and demand issue so I feel
as though the real point of contact is
going to be where we say hey teaching is
a wonderful noble profession that the
best people in society ought to be
aspiring toward and then when you have
people fighting to get positions in
teaching degrees like they do in Finland
that's when you can say well let's
ratchet up the bar and make sure that we
get the very very best I
that's the real issue so why are we
failing in stem and maths education in
this country I think it's probably a bit
of an exaggeration to say that we're
failing because I do think that some
things are really wonderful in
Australian education when it comes to
mathematics I mean I think about my
colleagues in the US and I know some of
them would dream to have the kinds of
opportunities I have here in Australia
where we get to teach from kindy to year
10 and have this coherent body of
mathematical knowledge that we get to
develop but that doesn't mean we still
don't have areas to improve upon and I
think the first issue is that
mathematics is just really hard it's a
very coherent subject where if you miss
out one little idea down here times
tables you had trouble with that well
times tables is kind of this foundation
for fractions which is the foundation
for algebra which then goes to calculus
and so if you sort of this is the
conversation I have with people when
they find out her math teacher they say
oh I was alright at maths until they
started putting letters in the mix and
man I just was completely out to sea
mathematics is kind of this funnel where
if you can survive to this point then
you can become successful mathematics so
there's a lot of early foundational
issues which cause us to have trouble on
a national level well let's go to those
early foundational issues lots of
parents are going to other programs like
Kumaon and and other ways that they're
they're trying to get extra help for
their kids do you support those sorts of
ways of giving kids extra help I think
that so long as there's a real intent
there to help children grow and to
become more confident and fluent in
their mathematics then I'm supportive of
those but I think the main issue is to
do with parents and I include myself in
this number parents mindset toward
learning mathematics I think in
Australia it's a very common attitude
that I hear when people say well look I
was never really that good at maths
anyway so you'll be fine if it wasn't
really a strong point you know focus on
your reading or focus on your touch
football or just do whatever it else is
in school that you enjoy and find
natural talent app but mathematics isn't
about you know people who find it easy
it's about being willing to persevere
and have a growth mindset towards saying
well I find this challenging now
but if I stick with it if I keep on
working hard and search for the support
I need I can actually grow and be
successful in this subject I think
that's the real issue that if I could
have every parents sit down with me and
I could convince them of one thing it's
that everyone really can do mathematics
with the right support let's talk about
the right support though what is the
right support and you said you know you
think if those programs work parents
should go to them but what should
parents be demanding of their primary
schools in their high schools I mean
what sort of conversations do they need
to be having about changing that
experience for their children well when
I think of parents again I come back to
my own experience my kids are 4 7 & 9 so
my oldest is in year 4 and I think that
the primary thing that I want to get
across to her is that mathematics number
one is something to be worked out as we
talked about before but number two
mathematics is everywhere it's so
crucial that no matter what walk of life
you're going to enter whatever sort of
career path you're interested in that
you realize and recognize that
mathematical thinking and mathematical
understanding are key parts of that so
when I come to school went out whenever
I talk to my children's teachers I want
to make sure that I'm in partnership
with them and I can help them say okay
these are the ways that I can help my
child see mathematics and numeracy all
around them and what ways can I connect
that and partner with the new kinds of
strategies they're learning at school I
mean mathematics and the way that it's
taught in primary schools is already
different from when I was at school and
so I need to keep up to date as a parent
and having a partnership and working
together with the teachers at school is
the only way that's going to happen
former New South Wales Education
Minister Andrew P Coley has accused
anglo-australian parents of caring too
much about their children's sport and
not not enough about their education I
desperately want your view on this have
you observed this - when Adrian piccoli
announced those words or they were
reported about him I definitely raised
an eyebrow because I've seen something
very similar throughout my teaching
experience that I don't know don't think
that angle Australians it's it's easy to
just categorize in one area I think
there are all kinds of people throughout
the world who definitely say I'll look
mathematics or your academics in general
that can take a back seat I'm a real
belief
in a holistic education and I think it's
important that children come out of
school having more than just academic
skills and being able to be really good
at taking tests so I want a child to be
well-rounded and have you know
leadership skills and the ability to
work in teams and collaborate with
others but I think that it has to be
kept in tension there has to be that you
know I play the acoustic guitar you
can't make music unless you have tension
in your strings and so I want to make
sure students have a well-balanced
approach toward that and usually that
means you know being able to compromise
on not just spending all of your time at
your books but also not letting
extracurricular activities completely
take over and prevent you from
especially in mathematics building the
foundation you need without which you
just cannot progress any further in life
students New South Wales Victoria and
the ICT are not required to study maths
at year eleven and twelve and they've
been calls to make maths compulsory just
like English is do you think that's a
good idea
I think at the current situation where
we're at in terms of making maths
compulsory we don't even have enough
maths teachers to teach it now when it's
not compulsory and so I think if you
made mathematics compulsory for every
single kid in the state or across the
country in the shortage of trained
passionate mathematics teachers that we
already have will just become even more
severe however I do think that there's a
wonderful statement that English makes
when we say English is a really integral
part of your functioning in society and
one of the things which I ponder is that
a few hundred years ago people thought
reading and writing or a special skill
that only particular people had and if
that was your job then good for you but
the rest of us don't need that and we
know much better now we know that
literacy is absolutely essential to just
function in society but we haven't come
to that point yet of understanding that
numeracy is the same and when I think
about when you open the newspaper and
you have a look at all the numbers and
patterns and statistics that just sort
of jump out at you if we don't have the
tools as a citizenship body to
understand what does this mean what does
this
what are you implications to me in the
way that I shop the way I work the way I
vote if we don't have those skills as a
nation that we're in some serious
trouble so ice
or the learning of mathematics across
the country but compulsory mathematics
for senior students we're a ways to go
before we get to that point Eddie whoo I
do hope you win that big prize and
congratulations again on being on the
top ten thank you so much it's a real
honor
[Music]